You meet a new acquaintance, and as you go
to shake hands after introducing yourself,
you suddenly realize “Wait...I already forgot
their name”. WHY does this ALWAYS HAPPEN
and what does it say about your brain?
Chances are you can remember someones face
over their name - our brains are hardwired
to recognize facial details. Brain scans even
show that individual brain cells are fired
in response to any given face. But when it
comes to forgetting names, it may have to
do with something called the baker effect.
If I tell you I’m a baker, I’m providing
information about what I do, and how I spend
my time, but if I say my name is Baker, it
has no mental links and is vulnerable to forgetting.
After all, names are completely arbitrary
and hold no specific information in them.
And if your brain can’t make connections
between multiple pieces of information, particularly
things you already know or feel familiar with,
then you’re more likely to forget that information.
Of course, it doesn’t help that you’re
often focusing on introducing yourself. This
is known as the ‘next in line’ effect.
Instead of watching and listening to the other
person, your brain starts focusing on it’s
own routine (What you’ll say, how you’ll
move, etc). And we simply aren’t very good
at both disseminating information at the same
time we try to take in and store new information.
Our brains have both short and long term memory;
but the short term memory or sometimes called
‘working memory’ can only hold so much
information, and if you don’t focus on it,
it fades away quickly [SCREEN FADES].
Finally, other research suggests that *drumroll*...you
may just not care. Honestly - you may be at
a party in which you’ll never see this person
again, or just generally uninterested in forming
a new relationship. Simply put, the more interest
you have in something, the more likely your
brain is to make new connections. As a result,
people who enjoy making new relationships
are tuned in and focused, and barely feel
as if their memory is being used or tested.
So how can you improve your ability to remember
names? We break down 7 clever tips to avoid
forgetting names in our newest AsapTHOUGHT
video, which you can check by clicking on
the screen, or using the link in the description.
These tips have been so useful to us! And
subscribe for more weekly science videos!